we are here today for the great
individual moments in the careers
[Applause]
history is the first ever player to hit
his 500 home run while wearing its
height
the numbers are great for casey 143 and
he's only 123 base hits what does that
stand out the two-two swing and miss
fastball up and away that's the fourth
scene fastball riding at 95. the one-two
swing and a miss he got another fast
ball away what a sequence they will face
carlos hernandez for the royals and the
royals are hoping he bounces back from
really one of his worst starts of the
year that sets the stage for miguel
cabrera very little doubt
how much the fans appreciate this man so
some baseball dignitaries here to
celebrate the moment the 1-1
right side and under the glove of
santana
they'll throw to first and they'll get
cabrera both runners move up there are
two away the tigers have them loaded
next pitch swung on hit to right dozier
coming on and makes the catch detroit
off the scoreboard two and one on the
year against the royals another one two
swung on it missed three punch-outs for
casey mize and he's done it against
three of their most dangerous hitters
tonight go with that curve again you
throw it the first time throw it again
that's the best change-up of the night
and that's carlos's first strikeout as
he's had two perfect innings to start
things off now the next one to o'hern
and a fastball bounced up the middle and
there's a base hit into center field so
ryan o'hearn with a leadoff single
line that is fair
off the sidewall
and a fan tried to grab it so hearn goes
to third on isbell's double and the
royals have runners at second and third
with one out
and he's gonna line it to right field
and that will be caught on the run by
grossman but that's plenty deep for ryan
o'hearn to come down the line and the
royals take a one-nothing lead in the
third miguel cabrera made a big out in
the first inning
that one's hit on one hop to nikki lopez
out at second and a double play cabrera
battles that bad knee alex lang has been
really good as of late it's his 33rd
appearance out of the bullpen and he
gets the six
they've struck him out twice tonight
though dowdy goes for out number two
here in the sixth and it's the depth of
that curveball and the over aggression
of silver pedes he he does not do that
very often crowd is just ready
to bust loose for miguel cabrera if he
can do something here
[Applause]
broken back grounder that's a fair ball
[Applause]
the throw not in time and the tigers
have the first two men aboard here in
the sixth it is a base hit modesty has
to go hard to his right and i'm not sure
if this ball actually hit the base or
not but you can see it hit off the heel
of his glove he couldn't find it maybe
hustling down the line by the way miguel
cabrera now 20 hits shy of 3 000 runners
at the corners now for eric haas and two
down
there's the payoff
right side fair ball
grossman trots home we're even at one
huss will dig for second and fall down
can't get out of it but he does deliver
the game-tying rbi squeezed it just
inside the first base bag eric haas
drives in his 57th run of the season
this one ties it at one on the c is 0
for two and then he had a ball go off of
his glove
and there's a fastball that's hit to the
gap in right center that's it for it
it's going to roll for a while monday
off to the races he's two second he's
not stopping there headed to third and
they won't even get a throw into third
base he's there standing up with his
first triple of the year this is a
triple kind of ballpark and he's a
triples kind of player so modesty
triples to the gap in right center and
the royals have a runner and third one
down for o'hearn
and o'hearn grounds it left side and
through
a big night for ryan o'hearn he is
singled and scored
and now he's driven in a run and the
royals regain the lead 2-1 boy that's
nice and that one there he waited and
went to left field beautiful swing got
him laying out of the game got his team
the lead
the o2
bounced off the chest of haas there goes
o'hern to second and he is out of there
what a throw by aaron haas what a play
by rose and rope he tried to block this
ball and scoots away to his right he has
to run over there and all in one motion
look at the strike he threw and he did
get him niko goodrum bats right-handed
for the first time he was o for two
that is grounded up the right field line
and off that corner there and that's
going to get goodram to second base now
he's going to try for third and a good
throw got him
you got to be convicted to go for three
there watch him see he's looking he's
doing what he should do but he slowed
down that cost him now he should have
stayed home hang with him nice relay
play like that it's going to get him
you've gotta you've really gotta execute
i mean that's a fair ball into the left
field corner by a diving monday why
don't you stop at second reyes will do
just that trot into second base he's got
himself a one out double
and the 2-2 pitch fastball at the knees
called strike three
and the pitch
and a curveball swung on and missed josh
stalmont gets the strikeout and takes
care of detroit kyle isbell will lead
things off for the royals in the eighth
a lot of room on the left side here's
the pitch a swing a shot to the alley
right center field that's going to get
down and go to the wall kyle might have
three reyes gets to the baseball he puts
the jets on and races to third for a
triple so isbell with a double and a
triple tonight that's in a big insurance
run at third base
and he's going to hit that one to left
field
cameron is there
and that'll get kyle isbell to the plate
and whit merrifield has his second
sacrifice fly of the night
and right after the tigers had a great
opportunity to tie the game with those
two doubles in the bottom of the seventh
the royals answer and they lead 3-1 in
the eighth miguel cabrera is one for
three
jammed the ground ball to monday
and for the second time tonight the
royals get miguel cabrera to ground into
a double play he comes set brings the o2
swung on and miss struck him out and
they leave the runner stranded at first
base two down in the bottom of the ninth
royals leading three to one
the one two he's going after it ground
ball right side with merefield there
picks it up and throws him out
and the game won now the series goes the
royals way a final score kansas city
three
detroit one